you could say it's the goal of art and
science to understand ourselves and our
brain our thinking is the most
interesting aspect of ourselves there
are three reasons to reverse engineer at
the brain one is to do a better job of
fixing it I quote one of the pioneers of
the neural implant for Parkinson's
disease is saying we're now treating the
brain circuitry not as a chemical soup
which drugs like SSRI drugs just treated
like a soup of chemicals it is in fact
an elaborate Network and if we actually
understand how that network works we can
do a much better job of overcoming
problems and limitations and for that
matter we're all limited secondly we can
create more intelligent machines we've
done a fairly good job without actually
understanding how the own brain works
but now that we're beginning to get
biologically inspired methods this is
going to greatly accelerate AI and
thirdly it'll provide more insight into
ourselves and we can't understand
ourselves if we don't understand how our
brains work and our identity our
consciousness the concept of free well
is closely associated with the brain now
it's not exactly the same thing we can
talk about how these philosophical
concepts relate to the brain but you
can't really have a kind of a discussion
about consciousness freewill and enmity
without talking about the brain
intelligence is also what we need to
solve all the major challenges of
humanity and of the planet and so on we
need more intelligence in fact we won't
be able to solve the major problems that
we have without more intelligence so for
all those reasons it's important to
understand how the brain works and it's
really only very recently I would say in
the last year that we have enough
information to actually make intelligent
statements about intelligence and how
you even tell
torence